[Music]
now the tornadoes came in the middle of
the night you need to head to your safe
place a series of twisters ripping
across the state of Tennessee a direct
hit by morning they were assessing the
damage more than a hundred buildings
destroyed dozens of people killed and
injured as they picked through the
wreckage of homes some knew they were
lucky to escape with their lives the
roof came crashing down on us and we
ended up between ceiling and floor we
couldn't get out we couldn't get out and
so I just kept kicking and kicking until
we finally made a hole and I was able to
get out and then I helped Harry get out
one of the tornadoes cut a 10-mile
swathe through a stretch of the city of
Nashville the hope for rescuers is that
people took shelter but the number of
those known to have lost their lives has
increased as rescue teams have reached
the worst affected areas the rest of the
community is in shock government can do
a lot of things initially to get things
started but there's a lot of hope and
rebuilding that needs to happen here and
and already we see members of the
community coming out saying what can
they do to help
Wow among the building's damaged a
historic church the damage to schools
and power lines and even polling
stations ready for Super Tuesday voting
was extensive the president will visit
the area on Friday we will get there and
we will recover and we will rebuild and
we will help them and condolences the
storms grew out of a weather system that
stretched across hundreds of miles for
some there was little warning just a
reminder of the unforgiving power of
nature Gregg Milam sky news